so here's the central question for all
of us who live in this country how much
power do the tech companies have over
our democratic elections American
Institute for behavioral research and
Technology senior research psychologist
Robert Epstein weighed in on that
question on this show watch we should be
extremely concerned because I can tell
you the bottom line here is content no
longer matters all that matters is the
filtering and ordering of content and
that is completely in the hands of
Google and Facebook I think the problems
can be solved at some point but at the
moment I think democracy is in trouble
well that probably woke you up dan
Bonjean was a contributor to NRA TV and
a frequent guest on this show he joins
us tonight Soudan why is this not a much
graver threat than Russia why is this
not a foreign threat from a foreign
country to the heart of our democracy
well well it is Tucker I think that's
obvious to rational people but that
assumes we're dealing with rational
people we're not we're dealing with
politicians and a media swamp that's
interested simply in combating Donald
Trump and they believe I believe wrongly
that the Russian narrative works for
them but this targeting of conservative
content is very real
anyone on these social media platforms
has experienced it I've experienced it
myself I actually have the trifecta for
you I was banned from running ads on
Twitter for what they cited is
inappropriate content which is odd
because all I post is conservative
content that's all I do they never
explain what the inappropriate content
was on YouTube our videos for our
podcast get flagged all the time they
have a little yellow button and when it
turns yellow you can't earn any money on
it now that doesn't happen as often to
liberal friends am I to do the same
thing and on Instagram we have a tough
time getting a blue checkmark despite
you know 60,000 followers so this is
very real and when it happens to
candidates running for office which
we've seen it's even worse but it
doesn't even need to happen to
candidates to threaten the rest of us
because it shuts
down part of the conversation and that
inevitably has got to have an effect on
how people vote if you don't hear ideas
obviously you can't internalize them so
why isn't that right they're a threat to
our elections no it is and and they want
what they want is they want their you
know they want to have it both ways what
they want Tucker these social media
platforms let's be clear on this they
want them protections of being an open
platform in other words in plain English
hey we're not responsible for what
people post don't see us exact then on
the other hand they treat themselves
like publishers they have these they
call them they do get the know what
catchphrases
the algorithm Tucker that's really a
selective process of weeding out
conservative content and giving favor to
liberal content in the new public space
you can't have it both ways guys exactly
an algorithm is editing let's think that
that's what we used to call it in
journalism dan bungee No thank you for
that